good afternoon Millennials sorry good
afternoon Millennials hope everybody's
having a good day um there is no
scheduled episode of the toast as you
guys know today is Columbus Day so we
didn't have an episode planned but
Jackie and I felt like compelled
compelled to do an episode yeah given
everything that's going on in Israel and
to make it a separate episode from
tomorrow's episode where we hope to be
able to do our show as usual but like
we're not the same girls we were on
Friday show yeah things are very much
fluid in terms of like toe scheduling it
just feels so unimportant we'll do shows
but I'm just saying like the tone and
the tenor of them is might not be like
what you've come to be used to from us
and as much as like we love to bring
light on days that are dark there are
some days that are too dark yeah and the
light can't get through and like that's
how we feel right now and this episode
is just meant to be like a conversation
about October 7th in Israel what
happened the facts of what happened
because from what I've seen on social
media not everyone knows or else they'd
be speaking differently if they [__]
knew right what happened what's
happening on social media and in the
media and the disappointing response
from in America so many celebrities
influencers
morons and how we feel about it yeah so
for those who may not know Jackie and I
are sisters we are Jewish we are
extremely proud zionists We have visited
Israel many many times it is a homeland
of our people we are huge supporters of
Israel um and on Saturday morning which
as most people know is is Shabbat for
for the Jewish Community it was also um
a holiday it was sh yes thank you um
which is a very holy day so if you are
observant at all like you're not on your
phone you're not watching TV you're just
in the holiday celebrating we uh we woke
up later to find out but at 6:00 a.m. um
in Israel Israel was attacked by Hamas
which is a terrorist organization people
on social media are going to try and
paint it as something else but don't get
it twisted Hamas is a terrorist
organization an organization of
terrorists not a hot take is what they
are they're they don't do anything else
they don't do any school build
charitable Works they commit acts of
Terror for decades against Israel
against the Jewish people all over the
world and Saturday morning was the
Saturday was the deadliest day for the
Jewish people since the Holocaust so in
addition to thousands of rockets that
were fired from Gaza into Israel
terrorists on foot invaded invaded
Israel invaded Israel neighborhoods
residential homes places of business
there was a music festival happening in
the South um it was called the Festival
of Peace where thousands of Jewish
Israelis tourists from out of the
country Christian Israelis Muslim
Israelis gay Israelis straight Israelis
it was a a festival for peace people par
uh excuse me not people terrorists parag
glided in and
just I don't even know what the right
wording is mass Massac Mass there are
now as of today we're recording this
episode on Monday afternoon there are
now about 900 people dead over a 100 of
them have been captured and kidnapped
mostly not 100 of them 900 people dead
over another hundred have been kidnapped
and taken back to Gaza mostly women
children
elderly um there so over 2,000 are
wounded and that's not just like oh I
twisted my ankle oh I that's a
life-threatening wound your life will
never be the same that's 2,000 people
yeah um and it just hasn't stopped since
then so it's now day three of War it's a
war a full-blown War the state of Israel
which is the homeland of the Jewish
people our people is under attack and as
if that wasn't like Haring enough to
wake up on Saturday and and I think as a
person who is Jewish and supports Israel
and follows what goes along in Israel we
are very sadly accustomed to like waking
up some mornings and hearing about
Rockets or terrorist attacks or
stabbings or you know suicide bombers
blowing up buses so it's not uncommon to
wake up to news like that however on
Saturday I think we all felt like this
seismic shift like how different this
was it was a full-blown War it wasn't
just like a rogue terrorist or a onetime
thing it was all over they made it into
Jerusalem which is you know much more
North it is a full scale attack on
Israel they're calling it Israel's 911
but the scale of the attack when
adjusted for the size of the population
of the USA the amount of people that
were killed in Israel that would be the
equivalent of 25,000 Americans dying in
one day which has not happened so this
is
catastrophic I'm sure some people have
seen videos they're really um hard to
watch but you have to watch them you
have to see what they're doing or else
you you wouldn't believe it and it's
easy to turn your a blind eye to it but
if you've seen it there's no other side
at this point all this time people are
like you know there's two sides and at
this point you either support Zionism or
you support terrorism that's it yeah
some of the footage is horrifying and
just hearing firsthand accounts you know
I've seen a lot of like uh people whose
daughters or fathers are missing or
kidnapped and they're what they're going
through is unimaginable I think um it's
not a question as to why so many of the
people kidnapped were young women these
young women are being raped and they're
being tortured and their families are
being called so that they can hear their
daughters and their mothers and their
sisters and their aunts being raped over
the phone like these are the most being
kidnapped is one of the most horrifying
experiences ever but you're being
kidnapped by the most evil people in the
world and they are doing unth and
Unthinkable things at every
turn everything that they are doing
is completely barbaric first of all
coming in invading homes going house to
house butchering families if they
couldn't get into the house they burned
down the house until families ran out
capturing the women and children the the
vulnerable the elderly a holocaust
Survivor right imagine surviving the
Holocaust and and then living through
this paragliding into a music festival
raping the women capturing them holding
them captive if not killing them then C
kidnapping them back to Gaza calling
their families on the phone and mocking
them going into an elderly person's
house murdering her taking a picture of
it and posting it to her Facebook wall
for her grandchildren to see it doesn't
get more evil than this if you don't see
that that this is good versus evil and
you feel ambiguous and you need a bit of
Grace to find the time and the words I
have no time for you yeah so as if like
waking up on Saturday like wasn't
traumatizing enough like seeing all this
footage hearing from people on the
ground what's what exactly is going on
and then having to adjust and and
receive what's being said here in
America I honestly I it's so
disappointing and it's it makes the
situation so much worse and the fact
that there's this weird social media
like rule where like if you say I
support Israel if you I'm a proud
Zionist and I think in recent years
there has been like an intentional um
campaign to make the word Zionist be a a
four-letter word like you support
Zionism they're equating it saying
you're a white supremacist which is just
beyond moronic because I can't even get
into how white supremacy everyone in
Israel is brown so so this is not like a
white this is not a race thing right
especially when the terrorists they
don't they're they're there to kill Jews
but they're there to kill anyone who
stands for freedom and people don't even
realize right now that's Israel but you
don't even realize that's you too right
and the people who are advocating for
Hamas like they're coming for you too
Israel is the only democracy in the
Middle East so I know that's it's kind
of like a just a thing people say but
like what it actually means is like if
you're a gay person and you want to live
in the Middle East there's really only
one op option for you and that's Israel
if you're a woman who wants to literally
do anything and you you want to live in
the Middle East there's only one option
for you so to to live in a culture
that's you know that is so wonderful
where we love gay rights women right
human rights just basic basic things to
see people who advocate for that being
like well I need to read an article
before it's really complicated it's
really not [__] complicated it's so
disappointing and I I hate to put so
much emphasis on like what I'm seeing on
social media because it's so unimportant
but but it's not no because it's too
twofold and it's a twofold war it's like
the war on the ground and then this our
reaction to it the public the war for
public opinion and and the thing is like
these things matter and I I at the end
of this we'll talk about how people can
support Israel and like what can they do
but just supporting Israel it means so
much to your Jewish friends but just to
the cause in general the fact that it's
not unequivocally like there was a
terrorist attack it was the most
gruesome thing like something out of the
Middle Ages like pillaging of villages
raping up women taking them as like War
trophies paring todders parading them
through the streets naked raping them
killing them and then literally tying
their body to the back of your truck as
some sort ofing on their dead naked
bodies the fact that it's not
unequivocal that you're going to condemn
it instead we need time to contextualize
what there's no first of all if you want
to go get your context Israel is still
right but after you do that there's no
ifs ANS or butts about this if you want
to talk about the history and who the
land belongs to it's still Israel but if
you want to go read some article that
will convince you that it belongs to
Palestine which is a name that was the
land was called by by the Roman Empire
after they conquered it from Israel
you're right it does always go back to
the Roman Empire the Roman Empire the
Roman Empire is what they conquered the
land of Judea from the Jews they called
it Syria Palestina and this has been
happening ever since and who called it
the land of Palestine the British right
it was a British
mandate so so if you if you do want to
go get the context go ahead just make
sure you get your fact straight but
regardless of that if you see what you
saw there is no justification or
contextualization that makes anything
like this relatively okay and if you
can't unequivocally denounce it that was
bad but if there's a butt at the end of
your sentence [__] off [__] off you are
you are evil you are on the side of evil
all it takes is for you to see those
videos and be a [__] human being to
know that that's wrong it has been
enormously disappointing and actually
really like scary to see the amount of
people with platforms the amount of
people who you know you work at Vogue
like these are people with the girl with
the boots the girl with the boots the
girl who Kanye made fun of her boots
they were [__] ugly and she's the
worst right so these are people with
enormous power enormous platforms these
are people with with responsibility to
to do the right thing 70 student groups
at Harvard like it's and and I feel like
for a lot of times as a Jewish person
who is aware of anti-Semitism you really
feel like you're shouting into a void
like we know Academia is incredibly
anti-semitic like there are so many
instances of Jewish students feeling so
incredibly unsafe on campuses so many
hate CRI unsafe being being unsafe so
many hate crimes like we know this and I
think unless you're in it like all of
this sounds crazy it sounds like there's
no way Harvard but like there is and and
the Jewish Community has been trying to
tell you this for years and you haven't
been listening and now it takes it takes
raping it takes murdering it takes
kidnapping for maybe for you to open
your eyes maybe but it's so crazy that
all of this and it's not an
unequal condemnation of Hamas yeah no
it's it's insane and
I I have to say that um I feel actually
really proud this part's like obviously
going to make me cry I feel really proud
that like you and I are so um like proud
of our Judaism and on our support for
Israel because I really feel like that
is translated to the toaster Community
like and I I know most of our listeners
aren't Jewish we have a lot of Jewish
listeners and and we love you and
appreciate you but the beauty of the
toast is that it's really for everyone
like no matter who you are what your
religion is like you can enjoy the toast
we love you you love us and the the
support from the toaster community and
like the the the energy to think
critically and the energy to do research
and and to not just believe what moronic
celebrities with enormous platforms are
saying it it's it brings great comfort
to me and it makes me feel really proud
of the community that we've built and it
doesn't go unnoticed and I just really
appreciate it and I think I'm even more
um incentivized or um what's the word
I'm looking for activated to keep doing
it because it's it's rewarding to see
and it's just a small corner of the
internet and of social media not that
small but I do feel like it makes an
impact to Smart list and I really
appreciate it I really do no I
appreciate it too I've gotten so many
kind messages so many horrible messages
I hope all you Jews die and Hitler was
right all all of that but to me that's
less shocking the POS the outpouring of
love and just all of these toasters in
the community who have learned so much
from us including learning how to go out
and think for yourself and see and find
information but what's also crazy it's
like yeah the celebrities are morons
they post dumb [__] and they regurg to
date the same you know week
graphic what was it and we need to make
space we need to make space um but it's
the media too and the med and the media
is the worst and they set the tone that
trickles down but their headlines I
posted on my story this newsletter that
I call them out what's their name need
to know newsletter bought by cheddar so
it's Cheddar's need to know I've been a
subscriber always 10 years I always talk
about my newsletter I found the story in
my newsletter by the way they've always
been horrible awful about Israel like
you know always
if Gaza launches rockets and Israel
retaliates Israel storms Gaza with
rockets so it's never like the the whole
truth but like that's what you come to
expect from the media so where am I
going to get a newsletter that doesn't
say that really but the fact that this
Mo on Monday
morning what I posted to my Instagram
you know Israel at War Israel uh Reigns
Rockets down on Gaza are declares war no
mention it was a slaughterfest yeah
blood lust like like we've never seen in
our lifetimes or in this Century yeah
yeah anywhere I think a really important
context I just have started to [__]
hate that word because it's just um this
is an excuse no it's like it's an excuse
for people but you know what go get your
context here's context read some [__]
history actually maybe even context
wasn't the right word it's a like a
detail because what's so terrible about
this whole situation is the amount of
Civilian casualties like if you enlist
in the Army like it's a it you know it's
a risk and you know that war is between
Army vers Army and I I heard a mother um
her it's such a terrible story her two
daughters were kidnapped they were in an
apartment together they called their mom
they're like someone's trying to break
in someone's trying to break in and she
heard the whole thing over the phone
12-year-old and 16-year-old still
missing and what she had said which was
really chilling is like even War has
rules and they have just thrown every
war every rule every you know moderately
war is terrible but you know you do
certain things to to minimize civilian
casualties it's like Rules of Engagement
these are war crimes and what's so crazy
is Israel is for years isra always
accused of war crimes Israel is the most
Humane military on the planet before
they drop a bomb on the house of a
terrorist who just killed a bunch of
innocent civilians they drop pamphlets
and they say go run even even this
weekend nanyu is telling civilians to
get out because things are going to get
crazy and so the detail I wanted to
mention is Hamas this terrorist
organization can't say that enough times
um they know this and they know that how
to get around that so what do they do
they stash all their weapons in civilian
homes they have their headquarters like
a bunch of high ranking officials their
office is in a residential building they
use their kids as human Shields they
make their CII civilians the casualties
so that they can paint a picture a
propaganda picture being like look what
was done you were given warning you were
told exactly what time and where you
were going to be attacked and what did
you do you flocked there with your
civilians it's so intentional and so
this storyline it's always like oh
Israeli IDF they killed children they
actually go out of their way to do the
exact opposite but their enemies make it
impossible to do so just keep that in
mind when you see the these headlines in
these numbers Hamas doesn't give a [__]
about the people who live in Palestine
they don't give a [__] Israel cares more
who just want to live their [__]
lives Israel cares more about them than
Hamas does so stop defending Hamas if
you give a [__] if you want peace if you
want coexistence you're never going to
win on the side of Hamas don't be
[__] stupid I know it's hard for a
lot of you I know and I sympathize with
that as a stupid [__] but I'm not that
stupid I know it's hard for you but get
a grip look around no and they'll make
it like it's about the land in 2005
people want to talk about an ethnic
cleansing in 2005 there was an ethnic
cleansing of every single Jew who lived
in Gaza who had a house there who bought
a home a community a Shool a school
pulled from their homes it was horrible
to watch and the Israeli government said
this is what we're going to do we want
peace like everyone get out of Gaza
this belongs to the Palestinians get out
and what did they do they used it as a
launching pad terrorist hot bed and the
people of Gaza elected Kamas as their
leadership like
it's this is what happened and the
Fallout is in America and I think it's
like it's it's dumb to even talk about
it because it's so far away but what
Israel represents in the Middle East is
exactly what America represents freedom
of religion love who you love like it's
a
free place yeah and so to see the
response in America in Time Square
yesterday hundreds of people suppor
country yeah I know but like in New York
it feels even scarier like the largest
the largest population of Jews outside
of Israel is New York La CH everywhere
hundreds of people showing up so excited
about this cheering this was a success
for them you're cheering for rape you're
cheering for murder they call them
Freedom Fighters the last thing on Earth
that they want is freedom for you it
it's it is imperative to support Israel
as an American like Israel is the
America of the Middle East and if you
don't get that then I can't help you um
but it's as simple as that yeah if and
if you if you stand for women's rights
if you stand for gay rights if you stand
for human rights human rights if you
value a human life there is no choice
here and it's so hypocritical and
contradictory that some people will go
so hard for Amica for one cause can't
even see how their cause would be
treated yeah by the people they're
supporting and I think uh another thing
and I really I don't subscribe to this
notion of like social media activism
agreed I I I I believe that you can
really care about something and not post
about it and it doesn't mean you don't
care even if you have a platform like I
don't I don't subscribe to that notion
but that is the culture that we live in
like if you don't post X you're marked
as X well here's how I yes how I feel
about it is but that logic doesn't apply
to this it doesn't apply here because I
feel as if you are someone who uses your
Instagram to talk about every cause
Under the Sun I'm hearing from you about
the Ukraine BLM then this is your time
to then you have to post about this well
War has been waged so when everybody
when you do every every cause and then
the Jewish one doesn't get the same
energy it makes you think well what is
the root of this lack of energy right
and it's an egregious thing and I feel
like up until this point I've never felt
so adamant about people having to post
when there are people who do activism on
their social media if you've never
posted about anything I don't really
care what you're doing that's not who
you are and that's that's kind of fine
no that is fine sorry I'm not like
unfollowing anyone who didn't post but
the people who post for everything and
they don't post about this it only leads
us to one conclusion and it's not and I
feel like when in 2021 there was a war
of the Rockets War where Trevor NOA
called them their pesky little brother
imagine your pesky little brother
running around raping pillaging right
murdering
has he said anything I don't know it's
we are keeping the list no there are
like a few celebrities and it's so dumb
to me and I don't agree like the fact
that if you want to stand with Israel
that's considered like a hot taken like
you can get canceled for it that's not
like the approved Instagram so crazy you
should get cancelled for sympathizing
with Hamas yeah for sympathizing with
the people who paraglide into a music
festival and Slaughter the innocent
civilians and the women rape them and
kidnap them those are not the good
people in this story right so the the
sheer fact that like supporting Israel
is this sort of Brave thing to do I
don't agree with it but it is the
reality of the of social media and now I
just like there you will never find me
in my life saying a bad word about Amy
Schumer like there are certain people
who like they they risked what they had
Sophia Richie like they they it's
unfortunately a risk it's moronic and I
don't give a [__] I'll post everything
but I understand for some people like
who are a little bit more removed from
it like there's a risk yeah and so there
are a few people whom I have enormous
respect for now and will be a fan of and
will see their movies and purchase their
skare like you have a fan in me forever
Jam Lee Curtis because it's so it's cons
it is brave yeah there are a few people
who I have lost all respect
for Kylie yeah Kylie there's a lot of
people posted and deleted I don't really
want Queen kept it up there twice post
twice what let's talk about the posting
and deleting cuz I actually think that's
worse than not posting at all because
it's like you saw everything you saw
everything and you were compelled enough
to post obviously but a couple messages
and you're a coward a couple and and
those messages were more important to
you than what you saw with your own two
eyes of what they did yeah I really want
to say some people's names say some
names they posted it it's public
information yeah the posting and
deleting is without a doubt like it's
humiliating yeah you stand for nothing
you stand for nothing like in times like
this it's really important to realize
how like none of this matters how many
people listen to your podcast it doesn't
[__] matter how many Instagram
followers you have I'm sure I have lost
so many followers like I don't give a
[__] and if you do like my God your
priorities are [__] and we were
talking yesterday you were saying how
it's most disappointing from someone
like Kylie yes okay it's most
disappointing from someone like KY I'm
going to use the example of like Sophia
Richie and Kylie oh no I don't think I
think Sophia Richie is oh yeah they're
the same no I think they're a little
different let me tell you why Kylie is a
billionaire she is aess probably till
the day she dies even if she never never
posted another like she is eternally
famous eternally successful nobody can
really hurt her you have nothing to lose
you know you don't have brand deals
being like oh we don't want this like
yeah and then your whole month is empty
of you can't make your rent I have no
respect for her posting and deleting
because that's a person who is
untouchable when I look at Sophia Richie
this is a person relatively new to the
A-list like she's at her Peak right now
she might not be at this peak forever
and even at her Peak with so many people
watching and really a lot to lose she
was adamant in her support for Israel
like that me is so respectable and so
honorable and someone like Kylie who's
Untouchable like what are you going to
do like what's going to happen to you
nothing to delete is so enormously
disappointing and I guess it really
shouldn't be surprising honestly like I
feel like I've definitely had blinders
on for Kylie for many years and like it
it shouldn't be surprising it's no it's
surprising that you had the balls enough
to
post and then none whatsoever yeah and
it's like you know at this point that
supporting Israel is the controversial
take so you posted it wa like you you
had the thought it's it's like kind of
like you knew you you had the thought
process you were going to make a tough
decision you did it you thought it
through and then you took it back like
you know yeah yeah Chris left her post
up Chris left her post and it's I hate
that like it's so unimportant that like
I'm putting value in stock in what but
it it changes the discourse it does it
makes an impact does no especially in
this situation where I feel like a lot
of times when everyone's posting for a
cause it's like there is no other side
it's meaningless you know what I mean so
it's like it it's what's fruitless no
what's the word we performative yes cuz
like what is this doing this is doing
nothing true it actually right this when
you post in support of Israel like it
helps it it helps change Tides like to
see I feel like most people if they
don't if Israel isn't top of mind for
them they're not Jewish they're not
thinking about the Middle East all the
time and they're not like up to date in
Jewish history and you just look at the
media like you really could find fault
with Israel so then to see like people
that you follow that you respect or even
friends of yours even if you don't have
a following just to see like oh oh there
is a lot of support for Israel maybe I
should look into this right no it it
moves the needle it moves the needle it
is so important right now like social
media activism In This Moment is so
important for Israel's cause because for
some reason it's not black and white
right for people like it's not like
there's an
obvious my God excuse me sneez on it
twice true when everyone was posting for
the Ukraine I didn't see anyone post for
Russia right no it was like that was
almost performative because it's like
obviously so like but but but it's not
so obvious now and so I don't know I
just I hate to put such importance on it
but I do feel like it actually changes
hearts and minds and it warms hearts for
people like us and there's so many
people like us who feel so alone and so
shocked and and devastated
heartbroken every feeling under the sun
and when you see that people support you
it matters it really does and so a lot
of the Outreach from people who follow
me in the toasters has been like what
can we do to help it honestly
I I feel like a lot of people can
probably relate to this I felt like this
general feeling of uselessness
like I I should be in Israel like I I
literally want to enlist in the Army
like I it's just this uselessness a and
like an oath what am I doing here like
my people are literally being
slaughtered and Ben has a lot of family
in Israel thank God they happened to be
in London but there's so many Americans
with deep direct connections friends
family a lot most of the kids from my
high school spent the year uh After High
School before College in Israel like
half the people and if if you're
wondering like why why should I care why
does this affect me well you you should
care cuz you're a human being but two a
lot of the victims are American a lot of
the hostages are hostages from Mexico
they're host hostages from Nepal this
isn't just an attack on the Jews and if
you don't care because it's Jewish well
you should look into that but if you
need a reason to care further this is
not just an Israel thing there are
people from all over the world who have
been killed there are people from all
over the world who have been raped there
are PE the girl I'm sure you saw her
picture beautiful girl from Germany who
came to the festival she's from Germany
she's not even Israeli actually I
believe she's a dual citizen but what
I'm saying is this is Israel is because
it's such a fabulous welcoming place is
a place for everyone so the victims are
everyone but don't get a twisted this is
very much about Jew and so if you don't
care or if you're finding a reason to
contextualize or doubt or say but just
admit that you don't give a [__] about
Jewish people dying it would save us a
lot of time I don't want to read your
statements you're not a good writer
you're not smart I don't want to read it
to just say honestly the Jews are not
for me I would honestly respect that
[__] more than lying yeah than lying
but what shut up also in the same that
they say death to Israel they say death
to America so this has to do with you
right like it's you
next if you don't do something so in
terms of people wanting to reach out we
have a fundraiser currently for magita
dome which is a fabulous organization um
that is helping injured wounded victims
on the ground they need money for
resources EMTs paramedics uh ambulances
everything we're almost at $200,000
which is amazing we are going to close
the fundraiser I heard some people want
to donate to UNICEF save your money
flush it down the toilet would it be
better suited if you did that okay um on
the ground we'll post on the toast
Instagram um a couple verified
organizations that you can donate if you
want to help people on the ground there
are so many wounded unfortunately there
are going to be more and this will help
them get the tools that they need and
it's really important to know that the
most of the hospitals in Israel
especially ones in the South are
treatment centers for everyone and that
includes civilians injured in Palestine
like that's the that's the energy in
Israel it's not the same you're an
injured person walking into Gaza best of
luck to you well you didn't walk in on
your own accord that's for sure
so yeah so yeah um so yeah that's how we
feel that's what's going on we wanted to
take like I honestly like I feel like
there are so few people who advocate for
Israel and it just wouldn't have felt
right to like do this and then like dive
into an episode I'm actually really glad
we had today off yeah um so we could
just sit and like dedicate time and let
this episode sit we'll see what happens
with the rest of the week we will be on
all week we'll be doing shows for sure
you know we've got
sponsored but
um thank you for listening for real and
thank you to The Toasters who have
really just been fabulous I've never
been more proud to be head that we've
built yeah for real like it it really
means the world to us to Jewish people
everywhere to human beings everywhere so
check our instagam sharing keep
correcting people and keep Don't Be
Afraid Don't Be Afraid these like I keep
wanting to say animal but like Theo's an
animal animals care animals love animals
have empathy these are barbarians I
honestly feel like that's an in
Barbarian beasts I don't I don't know
what the right word is but I'm not good
with the words it's subhuman but I feel
like Ariana took the meaning out of that
word our animatics yeah when she called
Rael subhuman yeah that's sleeping with
her mans right right perspective
perspective so thank you guys for
listening we adore you all we will be
back uh
tomorrow and have a great day okay and
I'm is I'm is
baby